good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday hope
everyone's having a great Tuesday hey
Jax how's your Tuesday my Tuesday is
good so far no complaints everything is
on schedule what can I say how's your
Tuesday I wouldn't say no complaints you
know do you have a complaint to Lodge I
mean if the Tuesday committee if I had
to like search within my soul to find
something to complain about like I
definitely could find you know issue
with the fact that it's literally only
Tuesday I know yesterday was a long day
I wasn't ready for it I was like about
to say Wednesday it felt like you know
I've earned my way to half through the
week but yeah not even close no
yesterday's show took it all out of me I
just needed some R R I actually got into
bed like at eight o'clock I didn't go to
sleep till 11 o'clock because that's
just me but I finished my book my book
about the plaza really really
interesting so many interesting factoids
honestly do you know that like the plot
you know how they turn the plaza into
Condominiums yes like have and do you
remember in 2005 when there was like
this whole like save the plaza campaign
no because they were converting so many
hotel rooms into condos and like the
hotel Union was like we wanted to
putting people out of work too it's the
plaza like give us more hotel rooms less
condos they came to some sort of
agreement agreement but it's a ton of
condos now and they're like the worst
investment like anyone really yeah like
people who have bought their and people
had to buy them sight unseen because
they were under construction and anyone
who's went to sell like lost money on
them wow they're like of the really
luxury condos in the city it's like the
worst investment well we really just
were on two different pages because I
read two erotic novels last night and I
think I'm like done with the erotic
novels they were both like so bad yeah
that's what happens this is what
happened it's a cycle yeah you read
something that's like really long hard
and boring like this book about the past
I think you're like I want something fun
flirty and easy then you read a really
dumb [ __ ] book and then you're like I
want to make good use of my time you
read something long dumb and boring yeah
so I read the new Tessa Bailey book
Killer vacation
um and it was so dumb like the thing
about Tessa Bailey and I think maybe she
does it on purpose like she has
characters with really bizarre jobs like
do you remember when I was recapping the
last book and it was so good but like
the girl was a part-time clown like
it was just so weird and like this time
the guy was like a bounty hunter and it
was just like kind of cringe he was like
this Renegade on the road no strings
attached like Bounty Hunter and it was
just like cringe so like I feel like she
does that on purpose but I don't know
like it's really weird
um so I'm ready for like an actual book
I've read enough like dumb stuff what
was the other book you read I was
talking about it yesterday
um oh you finished that book and then
read killer and was I disappointed I
understand like certain books being in a
series like
but I don't understand like leaving the
first book completely
untied like there was no resolution like
no ending it's like to be continued
that's where I draw the line yeah okay
so what's next for you an actual book I
think maybe like the wife between us I
said that that was pretty good that one
like got me but also I read that
in my early days of reading books where
like I was fooled all the time I'm still
easily full yeah now I'm a keen reader
and it's ruined reading for me yeah no I
feel that but like I If we're watching a
movie and like there's a Twist like
what's the biggest Shutter Island like
yeah I feel like a lot of people like I
remember seeing the movie and then
making other people watch it and being
like you never gonna know what to happen
and they're like and they guess I'm like
how the [ __ ] did you know that like I am
the last person ever on the planet
whether it's a book a movie a TV show to
Guess The Twist no me neither I remember
when we were also watching big little
lies and Alicia guessed The Twist that
you know the husband of Nicole Kidman
was also oh spoiler alert the father of
um
and the father of her kid oh was he also
the father
yeah and then Nicole Kidman's kids were
like hurting other kids in the class
because that's what they were seeing at
home you know I knew that but it never I
don't think I ever put together
this is exactly what I'm talking about
that he well I guess it makes sense
since he was the one who attacked her
but I never put together that he was
also the dad yeah and they were all half
Brothers now how cute really cute well
not really but but anyways well I was
watching it it never occurred to me that
we were even trying to solve who the
father of Shane and would leave kid was
and that if we found out it's going to
be connected to the rest of the story
now that I'm a reader that [ __ ] always
happens and I might have been able to
spot it so my friend Alicia said it and
it was so absurd I'm like there is
literally no way Alexander Skarsgard is
this guy and I brought it up at our
dinner table and everyone looked at me
and they were like
that's it like yeah no you're kidding
you just spoiled it first I'm like no no
you guys it's so absurd it's not
possible yeah and everyone was like mad
at me I'm like am I so dumb I thought it
was literally the dumbest thing that
ever came out of my friend Alicia's
mouth and she was 100 right yeah so now
being a keen reader you can spot that
stuff from a mile away not me like I
will always be the girl who has no idea
like what the twist is well I would
maybe recommend to you the book we just
read for the redheads because it's very
Dolly and James Patterson run Rose run
it's giving Nashville the show and
Country Strong the movie in a book hmm
I'll think about it yeah it was good and
everybody who read it in the redhead
said that it went by so quickly yeah I
just like there are certain things like
of course nothing is certain in life but
I just feel like something that was
close to certain was that I'd never read
a James Patterson book you know yeah no
I would have thought the same I I would
I'm always open to it but how do you
like jump into the Alex Cross series
when there's 19 books right I'm glad
that I did though but then like people
were saying in the redheads comments
like isn't it known that James Patterson
doesn't write his own books and he has a
Ghostwriter how do you become a famous
author who doesn't write his own books I
mean that's a question for Carol
radzwell since she was accused of having
a ghost writer like maybe at this point
in his career people can write in his
voice likeness and he can write all
these other books but to get started as
an accomplished author
you can't have a ghost right it's
literally like the Chicken and the Egg
yeah so I'm sure maybe he has help now
because his Trope is pretty and he's so
famous and Rich but I imagine it's the
Patterson special and I'm sure he didn't
phone it in for his collab with Dolly I
will always always think of Jeffrey
Epstein when I think of James Patterson
which is terrible for James Patterson he
didn't do anything wrong that I know of
yeah no but he inserted himself into
that documentary and now that's his
legacy for people who don't read his
books and his commercials yeah I'm James
Patterson by my book that I maybe didn't
write
um so it's Tuesday we've got a great
show juicy stories kind of
um yeah yeah glad you chose the stories
today I did Bryce is good thank you for
asking but he is he's wild and like this
morning something was crawled up and he
like was literally like scratching he
was on the bed but also like up on his
behind legs and on me like scratching at
me like Bryce you're gonna fall off the
bed and what can I do for you what did
he want I don't know I wound up giving
him a bully stick and that satiated him
and more importantly has Harrelson he's
so great
always he really loves his auntie he's
an anti-file can you admit that like I
definitely have a way with Harry I did
not have a way with Michaela every time
that [ __ ] was in my arms like she was
crying crying crying it's still to this
day I know she hates me like we like I
love she doesn't understand the love I
have in my heart for her couldn't move
mountains and she couldn't be bothered
to care like she doesn't love me like I
I know in my heart but she loves you but
she doesn't like you yes that's it and I
just never felt like when when I was
holding her it was like the Clock Was
ticking until she would start crying
yeah but with Harry I'm like he cries
and like I like I kind of like soothe
him yeah no he likes being much guard
and you're the macher yeah I like to
like fuss and bother him like Michaela
wasn't like that he wants like the more
action the more kisses the more songs
the more bouncing he wants all of it
yeah okay was like more to herself she's
kind of like introverted yeah yeah no I
can't really she came out of the womb
like this
I'm shy but Harry definitely like enjoys
my chaotic energy yeah he's a chaotic
King whereas kaler is more calm and he
loves to be entertained and you are an
Entertainer yeah no it definitely gives
me hope like when I was like obsessed
with Michaela and like she would always
cry I'm like I'm gonna be a terrible mom
and I guess I just need to make sure
that I give birth to children who enjoy
chaos yeah and energy who likes to be
like yeah like fussed with yeah totally
you'll get some I mean I think all kids
are different and I think assuming you
have more than one nurture nature right
nurture nature even if no no if they're
born like they don't want chaos I'll
nurture them to enjoy it okay but
assuming you have more than one some
will want it more than others and that's
just your cross to bear yeah it's just
like a cross I'm not really excited to
Bear if I'm being honest yeah like
raising kids oh
yeah it's the most important thing
you'll ever do too much pressure but I
did play Madison Square Garden
thanks for humbling me
that's what I'm here for
um okay should we dive in like anything
else you want to chat about no Claudia
chose the stories today so they're very
you know light and Airy you but you know
was there other stories that I didn't
choose well like something I would have
chose that I saw that you would never
have chosen was that like the original
historical fiction the original life the
original Gerber baby has passed away at
the age of 95. but everybody knows her
Fox oh okay okay well that's actually a
good story I didn't see that but let's
talk about that about a story when did
when I think of the original Gerber baby
I'm like oh the one when I was born but
no you know the one on all the cans oh
it's the name on everybody's lips is it
a boy or a girl girl and is she still
the face I think so let me go to the
article I didn't think you would be
interested but no that's cute obviously
not cute someone died but like uh at 95
and like being a thriller baby what a
legacy yeah
that's
how he could totally be a gerber baby
here you go her name was Ann Turner cook
oh my God this is her like as an older
person and that's her as the Gerber baby
you know that face yeah yeah that's a
really cute baby by the way the thoughts
that launched a thousand baby foods by
the way Harry has what it takes to
totally be a grouper baby that fat that
fudge but I don't have what it takes to
do no no no no no there's a lot of
Bravery that comes with being a stage
mom no and it's like bullishness
like to be a stage mom you must be above
on you must like put yourself and I'm so
I'm shy yeah I don't think I could I
don't think I could be a stage mom for
totally different reasons like if one of
us is gonna be on stage it's me right
not my kid right you can be Sage empty
but still same problem yeah like move
kids if you're like you know pitching
someone it's yourself obviously you're
not
no no no
well thank you Gerber baby and for all
of your work we appreciate you yes we do
rest in peace rest in peace so now
without further Ado here are the fast
five stories that Claudia chose before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
I feel like in case today's episode like
doesn't come out good like you keep
saying that I chose a story it's like so
it'll be my fault no that's really not
it it's mostly so that like uh if I
don't know what I'm talking about I can
say it's because I chose them you know
like this Olivia Rodrigo story because I
didn't like bust in here being like I
want to choose this choice and you asked
me I did because you were here and I
wasn't okay and the iPad was here so you
could use them it's more so if it's like
if I sound like you know a grandma
trying to use a microwave yeah this is
why okay well today's Grandma tried to
use a microwave moment is brought to you
by all birds all birds make shoes and
clothes that are better for you and
better for the planet using
revolutionary premium natural materials
their tree flyer is lightweight super
springy and wildly comfortable making
your long distance running efforts feel
surprisingly effortless they provide
unbelievable cushion and comfort so even
your toughest runs are easier on your
body so it's more balanced with less
ounce the tree flyer is light in weight
and in carbon footprint the
Revolutionary Swift foam midsole is
super lightweight and big on cushion and
energy return so you welcome spring with
every step now obviously I'm not a
runner but I do wear all birds quite a
bit just because like as someone who
like
gets you know foot pain just standing up
it's nice to have a nice supportive shoe
when you're running through an airport
you know
um walking down the street so I'm not a
runner but I do really like all birds
they're long distance comfort with
Superior grip a silky smooth Breezy
eucalyptus fiber upper hugs your foot
and keeps air flowing for Miles lace up
the tree flyer and get running today at
allbirds.com that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s if you're ready to go to
the Disc Go the Distance with a shoe
that will get you to the Finish Line let
the tree flyer put some spring in your
step allbirds.com
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s.com today's episode is
also brought to you by bowling Branch
bowling branch uses the best 100 organic
threads on Earth for Superior softness
and a better night's sleep their sheets
aren't just buttery breathable and
impossibly soft to start but they get
softer with every wash one thing about
me
I'm a bowling Branch girly pillowcases
duvet cover throw blanket literally
everything in my home is from Bowling
branch and I wouldn't have it any other
way and I had them before they were a
sponsor because
um I was influenced by rage parcel like
if it's good enough for her Utah Mansion
it's good enough for me so what I have
and I think you have a two right the
signature hem she's signature sheets and
the blanket I love but I actually just
got uh fresh kums of fresh fresh cakes
from Bowling Branch so the hemmed the
signature hem sheets from Bowling Branch
are their best seller for a reason they
use high quality threads for Superior
softness and a better night's sleep
their sheets are made with luxurious are
made so luxurious that they are beloved
by three U.S presidents they feel
buttery soft to the touch and are super
breathable so they're perfect for every
season and they have over 10 000 Stellar
reviews so get 15 off your first set of
sheets when you use the promo code toast
at bowl and branch.com that's bowling
Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch.com promo code toast it's good
enough for the presidents and it's good
enough for Rachel parcel it's definitely
good enough for you
our first story Luanda steps and Sonia
Morgan land's simple lifestyle reality
show
Luanne and Sonia have signed a deal to
star in their own show page six has
learned according to sources close to
the production it'll be a simple
lifestyle reality show in which the
Glamorous Pals will live together in a
middle American town and mingle with the
regular folk much like Paris and Nikki
did in the original Fox series we're
told the paperwork is signed and they'll
start filming the as yet unnamed show in
July apparently it's still technically
in development but it's considered a
lock to get greenlit any day now so I
have to say conceptually I think this is
a great idea I think they definitely
have that Paris and Nicole energy in the
sense that like I don't think that
either one of them have like experienced
real life in years whether it was
because Sonia was a Morgan and Countess
was a countess so the conceptually this
is a good idea I am just confused as to
like what this means like because
they're also doing Roni Legacy is this a
Bravo show it sounds like they worked
with a separate production company it
doesn't say I would assume it's peacock
but it doesn't say yeah yeah where it's
going and I do think that they could do
Roni Legacy this they're doing ultimate
girls trip they're doing like a lot of
different spin-offs they're both on tour
of housewives in general so I think
they're just trying to get content for
the streamer by the way that's a great
idea and I think this if it is on
peacock makes it like an even better
idea it's like perfect for peacock I
don't know if it needs to be on cable
yeah and not to be a hater but but I
don't want to watch this oh really yeah
it just when like Paris and Nicole did
it it was so authentic and like we know
that the these two are silly and it's I
can just imagine it's gonna be annoying
okay I could see that they're annoying
just being on the show being goofy and
dumb and now they're gonna what like go
LARP as middle Americans like yeah I'm
not it just sounds annoying okay the
concept but I understand why the head
the Han shows at NBC or thought this
might be a good idea but I just feel
like in practice it's not something that
I want to watch that's fair I mean we do
have to wait and see so I agree
conceptually it's a great idea in
execution we'll have to wait and see
um but I think it could be good I do I
mean obviously you're never going to
recapture the magic that was the simple
life like if you don't own that on
Amazon Prime it's like the only place
you can find it I'm always afraid it's
gonna like disappear it is a worthy
investment in your future it is
probably top five most iconic reality
shows of all time yeah it's so good it
is though because and also it was in the
early days like now even something could
be a great show but if it's a format
that's been copied it's not an original
you know that was the oh that's true the
idea the execution everything and they
are so talented funny and interesting
yeah and they just like they didn't the
thing with reality TV now is like if you
get on reality TV like you want it so
bad like you try so hard you have
something to prove because you know what
becoming a reality star can get you Kim
Kardashian and everyone thinks that
they're going to be the next one but
with Nicole in Paris like they literally
had nothing to lose like they just were
being themselves being funny like it was
not
it didn't take it seriously it's very
formulaic now like you know you do this
that this and that this hits with
audiences that doesn't if you want
longevity maybe you know be the villain
or whatever but then there was no
knowing what was going to work so they
just were themselves yeah and that's
what worked and I think now when I think
back okay like I was gonna ask you like
top five reality shows of all time
they're all like
oh really old yeah pretty wild but it's
also because they were the first right
and so that's how you just associate
but I also think like the content was
better like I was also going to say
Flavor of Love which literally is better
than any episode of The Bachelor I've
ever seen in my life right the content
was better but now it's just because
we've seen it so many times like crazy
things are happening on The Bachelor all
the time now but it's not real it's not
real fatigue it's not real yeah like
when pumpkins spit in New York's face
like that was real yeah where were you
when pumpkin spit in New York's face
like that was a cultural shift so good
and then what's crazy is like where's
pumpkin you know New York is still very
much Tiffany Pollard I think she was on
The Apprentice like she's always doing
this she was on
what was that show famous in love yeah
that was a good show she has a podcast
she's always all over my Tick Tock she's
like classic Vibe oh she did Celebrity
Big Brother which I think was like a
huge um Resurgence for her because
people were like who is this and she was
so funny and that's where everything of
the sort nothing so sorry yeah I would
tell Gemma that she is a fat
who doesn't possess the vernacular that
she thinks that she does I would have
told her to put those shoes back on the
rack because she said a beautiful woman
needed to wear them and she is nothing
of the sort that is literally like
somebody lied to her several times and
told her that she was fly hot sexy and
beautiful and she is nothing like that
she's nothing of the sort
so good so good and I didn't even watch
Celebrity Big Brothers Who's Gemma no
but um I remember when it oh I know who
Gemma is she is like this British like
hot mess Queen like but um when I did
find out what that nothing of the sort
was about I did go down a rabbit hole
like Tiffany Pollard moments on
Celebrity Big Brother so there was a
contestant in the house named David
and you know they're cut off from
reality but somebody did find out I
don't know how that at the time like
that day David Bowie died
and so Tiffany found out and she thought
they were talking about the guy in the
house named David so she goes around
telling everyone that their roommate
David died and she's dead serious she's
like hysterically crying and it is
literally like Peak comedy wow maybe I
should watch that season yeah it's UK
right because gemma's British I think
yeah and and yeah I think so you should
watch that I know
like big brother no but there's so much
there if you decide to partake there's
so much there on like the CBS
reality show front like Survivor but I
just never got into it also remember I'm
a celebrity get me out of here that was
good for you that was so good
um Heidi and they were the whole show
yeah yeah yeah
that was insane that I watched when it
was on remember
um skating with the Stars
figure skating and then they had an
offshoot diving with the Stars and Kim
Richards and Kyle Richards were on it
like do yeah Olympic diving yeah
they don't know how to let a good thing
just be why can't it just be Dancing
with the Stars I don't know that's a
good call
anyways TBD on the show hopefully it
gets greenlit I think a lot of people
would enjoy it I just I'm not seeing it
for myself and that's okay that's okay
normalize like not watching things
normalize not everything being for you
yeah and you know something you said
like in a couple like weeks ago really
resonated with me because I feel like
given the fact that it's like my job to
be kept up on all things like I feel
like this and I know it sounds stupid
but like I feel this enormous pressure
to watch everything and like when I
start seeing content about like love is
blind and and it just like exhausts me
and I and like I'll be at home like not
watching
um what was the show that we were having
the conversation about oh the ultimatum
the uh the ultimatum yes exactly and I
was like uh but then you were like
[ __ ] has such a short shelf life now
like we're gonna exhaust ourselves to
watch 10 episodes of a show that we
don't even want to watch just to be
relevant for one episode of our podcast
when literally is anyone talking about
the ultimatum right now no and like the
time that you would spend watching that
show like you could read a whole book I
could read a whole book I could hang out
with my nephew I could literally like go
for a run she couldn't I could I won't
in my all birds because she has the
running shoes should she choose should I
to go for a run but she won't choose but
she could yeah if she wanted to so I
just wanted to let you know like you
saying that really um it like took a
like a chip off my shoulder that I
didn't know that I had I'm so glad yeah
yeah because it's so true ever even like
selling Sunset though the last season
was like oh my God oh my God and now uh
it's on to the next there's just so much
fanfare for [ __ ] these days because I
think like media and there's just like
people don't know what to talk about so
they talk about selling Sunset and then
it's like you're watching this and
you're like this stinks and I'm not
talking about selling sounds like it's
selling Sunset is okay even though it's
actually really bad this most recent
season I didn't finish the one before
was atrocious I didn't even watch this
most recent season the only time it's a
little I don't want to say sad but
not you know these piece of [ __ ] shows
like they're flashing the pan like as
they should be but then you've got a
show like Bridgerton which takes so much
time so much money so much production
value and it gets that same five seconds
of play like everything else yeah and
that's a little sad because it deserves
so much more I agree with that I do feel
like Queen's gamut got more and I think
maybe even Bridgerton gets more but it's
like
all of a sudden it's like it's like an
episode of the morning toast it's 24
hours and then it's in the bin yeah no
like you're right like it is weird the
amount of like money energy resources
and like passion people put into
projects to have like 45 seconds of Fame
it's not even 15 minutes anymore like 15
minutes is a long time it's literally 30
seconds yeah and you just have to like
scramble together all the Instagram
followers that you have right that you
can in that short amount of time and you
know try to engage them for the rest of
your life no it's good luck it's
exhausting good luck yeah that's a
really good call are you ready for our
next story yes because Pete Davidson and
Saint West hit Walmart without Kim
Kardashian the relatable King Pete took
Kim's six-year-old son to Walmart in
Woodland Hills California where they
would seem purchasing a big container of
cheese puffs among other goodies on
Saturday TMZ reported the outlet claims
Saint wanted to be a regular kid and run
around the store aimlessly but Pete
reminded him that if that Kim would be
pretty upset if he lost him they had a
busy weekend as they were also seen
holding hands as they made their way
into the Cheesecake Factory at the Grove
in LA later in the day they were also
spotted heading over to a shopping cart
filled with fun hats
we stand a chain restaurant King We
Stand The Cheesecake Factory and Walmart
like this and that's why the city will
just never be what it could be because
we don't have a Cheesecake Factory and
we don't have a Walmart and I did go to
a Cheesecake Factory recently like in
closest proximity to New York it was in
Jersey City which is literally only two
miles away it took me 45 minutes to get
there and once I got there I was like
this sucks like I was just not what'd
you get like you know everything how was
the bread not good I'm actually not
people like Quake over the bread from
Cheesecake Factory it's that's not
really why I go
like I'm not into you know I eat the
bread it's not like it's not an
experience for me okay what do you go
for like the food The Vibes the portion
sizes the diet coke the dessert like the
gorgeous architecture and interior
design Mediterranean style the size of
the bank cats the size of the bank cats
for sure the people watching I think the
people who work at Cheesecake Factory
are some of the nicest people like I'm
always making friends like I just love
it oh and also all for an affordable
price like you literally can't put a
price on that I mean you could but it
would be very low you can't and why
isn't the Cheesecake Factory in New York
like why can't we have anything no I
know and what happened to CPK like that
one hurt yeah but and the city honestly
has not been the same since California
Pizza the last CPK left but see the
thing is is that I think California
Pizza Kitchen as a whole has been
dwindling as a business whereas like
Cheesecake Factory is bigger and better
than ever we still don't have one in New
York do you know what I mean like I see
I feel like as a franchise California
Pizza Kitchen is like getting less and
less locations less and less popular and
so we were wrong we were just collateral
in that you know so wrong cake factor is
bigger and better than ever if you live
near cbk you need to go today in
solidarity and this is what you need to
get because apparently it's an off menu
item it's not on the menu Pizza the
tricolori salad it's a salad on top of a
pizza crust which doesn't sound good I
wouldn't want salad pizza but it's so
[ __ ] good it's so [ __ ] good and
you need to get the children's mac and
cheese because to this day it's the best
Mac and Cheese I've ever had and spinach
artichoke dip yeah and of course like an
extremely large Diet Coke and they have
good bread there yeah
what do I do what I would do you know I
had
um the last remaining
um
California Pizza Kitchen was on 33rd and
park yeah and like when I was in college
one summer I had an internship on 33rd
and Madison so and I hated it there were
three people who worked in the office
and it was dead silent like godford they
played music and I literally just like
watched Netflix and it was like this
startup and like
and like literally there was not one
thing for me to do I don't even know why
they hired me but like they paid me like
cash and I was like this rocks
um I literally used to watch Netflix
with my headphones in and it would slow
down the Wi-Fi in the office and someone
would be like is someone video streaming
and I would literally know what are you
talking about because I would literally
be slowing down the Wi-Fi but the only
you know Silver Lining of this
internship was that it was a block away
from California Pizza Kitchen and I
literally used to take a three hour
lunch break and sit my ass in that bank
cat and eat mac and cheese and it was
like really some of the like the fondest
maybe the best summer of my life picture
this
you're at cbk having a solo lunge by the
way normalize having lunch alone because
you're there to eat and yeah especially
like if you're an intern and especially
if you know when to go with it's better
than not having lunch at all yes picture
this you're having a solo lunch at CPK
you bring your Kindle oh yeah you gotta
try chlori salad Diet Coke mac and
cheese spinach artichoke dip life is
good yeah that was before my kid my
reading days but I would that would have
been nice like you could go to
lunch alone at any time now with your
Kindle definitely like that sounds nicer
than you know having forced convo with
someone not you like I would love to go
hypothetically somebody's you know
people say you're never alone when
you're with Christ but I say you're
never alone when you're with your Kindle
you're never alone when you're pregnant
that's so really true actually right
yeah so true you're also never alone
when you're with Bryce that's true
because he won't leave you alone until
you give him a bully stick
are you ready for our next story only if
it's the next story that's brought to
you by liquid IV it is when you push
your body too hard or just feel run down
it's extremely important to stay
hydrated and making hydration a priority
helps us all feel better on a day-to-day
basis so one stick of liquid hydration
multiplier in 16 ounces of water
hydrates you faster and more efficiently
than water alone and they come in
refreshing and delicious flavors like
watermelon lemon lime strawberry piña
colada and more so whether your
dehydration comes from lack of drinking
water or if you're hungover liquid IV is
a great thing to always have like in
your purse in your house in your desk
it's just a thing that can help you get
through the day it will immediately make
you feel better and there's like really
as much as a pants when you say like
nothing better than being hydrated so
one stick of liquid IV into 16 ounces of
water hydrates you faster and more
efficiently than water alone it contains
five essential vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 and
vitamin C and it has three times the
electrolytes of a traditional sports
drink it's made with premium ingredients
it's non-GMO and it's free from gluten
dairy and soy there are also on a
mission to change the world because
they've donated over 20 million serving
School globally so you can feel good
purchasing liquid IV knowing you're
going to make yourself feel better and
the world feel better grab liquid IV in
bulk nationwide at Costco or you can get
25 off when you go to liquid iv.com and
use the code toast at checkout that's 25
off anything you order when you use
promo code toast at liquid iv.com
experience better hydration today at
liquid iv.com promo code toast so for my
hangover girls my migraine girlies those
are two times when like I really need to
drink a lot of water I'll usually throw
liquid IV in there just like you know
not waste my time Juliana I drink a lot
of liquid IV totally free tagline for
you guys
next story Chris Rock and Dave Chappelle
to co-headline comedy show in London
Chris Rock and Dave Chappelle are going
to perform a stand-up show at London's
O2 Arena together later this year the
two U.S comedy Stars will perform on
Saturday September 3rd in a co-head
lightning gig just weeks after they were
both attacked on stage in separate
incidents The Joint gig at London's O2
Arena is currently their only UK
performance
okay so first of all this is just like
even if they weren't both just like
recently attacked like this is just a
great you know show yeah great
Headliners like gonna gonna do well
ticket sales wise but I do wonder if
like this is the moment where mostly
Chris Rock but also did you like finally
addressed we haven't heard from Chris
Rock since the slap I'm sure like he's
been writing material about it or at
least like Gathering his thoughts and I
would love to know I'm I just like have
a feeling Netflix is going to be there
like filming they're always just like
filming stuff yeah someone's always
filming stuff yeah so I'm curious if
this is like the moment we've kind of
been waiting for well apparently they
joked about it together
um at The Comedy Store they did a gig no
I know but like if it's not being filmed
like it doesn't count it's not it's not
your official statement of course but
say that they do this O2 show and
there's no streamer that puts it out
does it still count well I don't know
there's like a hundred thousand people
in the O2 as opposed to 50 people oh no
phones right like they always take your
phone yeah so I don't like I don't know
I I do have a feeling it'll be filmed I
don't know why I just feel like iconic
things like this don't just happen and
not get filmed right
it's too like you know
not for a streamer
like shows but it might not make its way
to us no when I say film I mean like
first streaming service
you would hope yeah but Chris Rock is
also on tour right now like is that
special gonna be a special right and
Chris Rock has said like he
had this material written for so long
he's not gonna throw it away just
because everyone wants to hear what he
has to say about Chris Rock right so
it's possible he's doing this that same
old material at this event right he
could add like five minutes yeah to give
us a joke the whole thing doesn't have
to be about about Will Smith but like I
am curious like what are his thoughts on
being slapped on TV you know does he
think it's funny
is he mad has he spoken like I'm just
beyond curious yeah and we've heard a
lot from Will Smith you know he got his
speech Jada did Red table talk like
he's really not the one I want to hear
from yeah I want to hear from the man
who slapped you should go to the show
totally hear from his mouth I've never
been to London you should go I know what
is it September 3rd that's like Labor
Day weekend where the hell am I going to
be in September like I that's people
really plan their whole years so crazy
Labor Day weekend yeah
ldw in London visit the queen labor with
EU right right visit the queen I don't
know
only if I get an invitation to
Buckingham Palace well anybody can go
and like stand outside that's not an
invitation no but like I would do that
you would if I take a picture yeah I
would go and look at all that crap yeah
yeah for pictures yeah which is like
when people come to New York I can't
relate like to go to the Statue of
Liberty no I couldn't buy a State
Building couldn't be me that couldn't be
me I've lived in New York my entire life
ask me if I've ever been to the Empire
State Building uh no aside from like
walking past it no I've never been up no
we didn't know that we ate dinner at the
rainbow room once oh that's gorgeous
yeah and I think maybe I've had like one
meeting there and like NBC is there no
that's 30 Rock oh it's nearby yeah
um and you know that the roof the
observation deck of the Empire State
Building is like an influencer and
they're always like dming people to come
they're huge on Tick Tock yeah they're
really big we're gonna get reached out
to now no I've already been reached out
to but I don't like heights
it's that when you're that high up the
wind is so crazy like if you're wearing
a skirt your whole vagina's out and like
your hair good luck okay so wear pants
and put your hair up
no uh no I just have no desire to go to
the Empire State Building but
I have a desire to be on a double decker
bus in London in front of the Big Ben I
have that design yeah yeah yeah totally
like if I ever do go to London like I'm
gonna be that [ __ ] like I'm literally
gonna walk around with like a minion
Jack t-shirt like winning London yeah
and I guess that's the equivalent of
people walking around in an i heart New
York t-shirt I know so that's always
what I wonder what would I think of New
York if I wasn't from here didn't live
here it would literally be Annie no I
would I would I would be Eloy Eloise at
the Plaza bags no you're Annie with your
red hair one me yeah I think I would be
like really jazzed about stuff you know
you would hop off the bus like with your
suitcase look around being like in awe
in awe I would
like would I go to Times Square yeah
but you're still you so you would go and
be like this is cool but like I'm never
coming back you know but it's something
I had to experience I wonder what else I
would want to see I feel like still I
wouldn't care to see the Statue of
Liberty we also have like double decker
buses here don't we those like big red
buses you could do like a real
housewives Tour on one I did a real
housewives touring it was literally like
in a van like that kidnaps people like
yeah it was like it's so neat it was
unique oh I would do horse and carriage
ride yeah and you would yell at me yeah
I feel like I would be very like Central
Park 59 like the plaza Burger area yeah
I don't think I would be going downtown
I don't think I'd be going to the Statue
of Liberty there's no way to know would
I take the ferry yeah you love the ferry
even though like you hate New York yeah
I mean the ferry is just like a really
easy way to get around because there's
no traffic yeah just like gorgeous when
you choose I always forget we live on an
island like need to get a boat yeah I
actually saw I was maybe I was on the
FDR and so I saw on the East River that
someone like was on like a boat that was
very like Miami like a real boat you
know like a sexy boat and they were on
the East River and it's like where did
you come from with your boat literally
we need water taxis
I think we have some like if you wanted
to go to like Governor's Island no like
within Manhattan like if I'm on the
Upper East Side and I want to get down
to fight eye like I could really like
take a boat and then like a very short
taxi or Subway yeah they have a ferry
for that they do yeah that goes up and
down North to South it also might stop
in Queens and Brooklyn but it could take
you from north to south because
sometimes like
um I would take it to go from the South
Street Seaport to Prairie Hill
interesting yeah
so that is the water taxi so it's not a
water taxi but okay we should have a
weekend of like New York no tourists
please don't do it for patreon if I say
that then you have to do it no please
like I don't think I've ever been to the
Statue of Liberty I'm taking you I've
never been either you should scale it oh
no and you go to like Ellis Island which
we've definitely seen some field trip
I've no I've never been to Ellis Island
you've not seen it on a field trip no I
feel like I have
I'm happy for you I'm having like Alice
flashback right right oh no we've got
Ella's flashbacks
uh you could take the um the tram yeah
I've never taken the tram Roosevelt
Island I don't trust that tram as far as
I could throw it that tram has been
going and going ever since I was a kid
and it gets slower and slower and I
never see anyone working on it heavier
yeah it's never seen any floor I never
see any maintenance I never see them you
know Grace in the lines I don't trust
that tram at all no that trap is scary
that trim is a big ass accident we have
never have heard anything about it it
goes every day people do it everywhere
where does it go to Randall Island
Roosevelt Island
same thing yeah half right okay are you
ready for our next story I am Olivia
Rodrigo had the best reaction to
spotting her lookalike on tick tock
Olivia Rodrigo is feeling some serious
Deja Vu on May 25th the Grammy
award-winning singer took to the comment
section of a hilarious Tick Tock to
share her surprise over a look-alike who
had recently attended one of the LA
stops of her sour tour like a look-alike
taken aback by how much the girl in the
video looked like her the 19 year old
remarked no I thought she was me too in
the clip her doppelganger can be seen
channeling the singer's iconic soft Punk
Style by wearing a lilac dress black
knee socks and a pair of boots she
completed her look with a pair of small
sunglasses multiple silver necklaces and
two braids the user wrote my sister
after one person said she looks like
Olivia Rodrigo no but like she really
did not even like her face but really
she got the outfit perfectly and also
like her mannerisms yeah so I saw the
video and I was like cracking up because
I also thought it was Olivia Rodrigo and
the girl like blew up on Tick Tock and
I'm so glad like I hate when like things
go viral for a celebrity in a positive
way and they don't like react to it and
like get involved in in the fun you know
yeah oh I'm looking at the video you
have to watch a video to like she walks
in the big boots she's wearing it's like
so Olivia and she's at the Olivia
Rodrigo concert so she's like covering
her face so that people don't like stop
her for pictures but that's so funny
because when you go to a concert you
dress like the artist you know if you
have a sense of fun and right like I'm
going to Billy Joel this week and I'm
going to shave my head
exactly because you have a sense of
funny
and so she went and trusted oliviera
negro and now she's famous yeah that's
very exciting for her and I'm glad
Olivia commented on it
um if you had to go to a concert and
like fully impersonate someone like who
would you you or not a concert like an
event if you had to be like a celebrity
top like a celebrity impersonator who
would you be oh like are you asking me
who I think I look like yeah but also
like who you could do oh well I don't
know if I'd ever be like
you know confused as someone but like
I've had a lovely time dressing as
Ariana Grande at her concert oh yeah you
know the high pony and those were like
back in the day when her style was just
like oversized sweatshirt very clear
yeah she's kind of like different now
yeah no she's changing she doesn't
always wear the eye Pony but like I have
my extensions in I had my thigh highs I
had my cat ears and then I gave them to
a mother because she was like looking
for cat ears for her kid and I was like
well I'm 20 something so that's so nice
yeah but I had switched with Sam earlier
in the night
um so I wound up giving Sam's to her and
I just like felt bad what did Sam say
she was like well first the mother
offered to pay me a hundred dollars for
them and I was like no dollars because
she really wanted them
no they were just you know they sell
them there but they were sold out and so
she was like can I buy yours from you I
was like no you can have them so I came
back to Sam and I was like shover me a
hundred dollars so he just gave them to
her and Sam like was like so where's the
money she thought I took the money yeah
it was like I had sold her right because
I was like no I didn't take money uh but
I was like you keep mine that's really
nice of you yeah so that was fun what
about you I mean I don't know if Snooki
performs but I would definitely
um go to her concert and channel her
energy go to one of her podcast shows
literally I think I would get confused
for Snooki if I went to one of her
podcast tours because everyone is like
wasted anyway yeah but like you're also
famous so now you just look like girl
with no job and thank you for saying
that you're welcome you're such a good
sister I try I really tried my best you
know where to hit me where where it
counts
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
add or sing first
it's the original question I'm not ready
so then I'm not ready you're not ready
to say no so then you must add
that today's Final story is brought to
you by osia oh she has been making clean
and Ultra effective skin care and body
products for over 25 years they use
seaweed as their product star ingredient
and their vegan and climate neutral
certified they have award-winning
cleansers serums and face moisturizers
and they're known for creating body
products like their Famous Body Oil so
everyone on tick tock tick tock uses
osea and I got their cleanser a while
ago and now that we're working with them
I got their body oil and their
hyaluronic acid so I've never used a
body oil before but like I don't know
why I never have it's literally the most
amazing product like my legs are glowing
like they're literally glowing so in
1990 since 1996 osia has been creating
clean vegan and cruelty free products
that are safe for your skin and the
planet and they've done it again with
their new body butter it is softening
nourishing and has the most amazing
Citrus scent it's even clinically proven
to moisturize skin for up to 72 hours
it's Rich texture feels so good and
applies smoothly without being sticky
and it makes skin look moisturized and
healthy and a little really does go a
long way so I've had the chance to try
it it pairs really well with their body
oil
um I like hate moisturizing my legs like
after I shave because I just find it to
be like really sticky and slippery and
like it never goes away it's like all
night in my bed and like feels licking
it it's like a whole thing and I find
the body better for most Sia to be
really really premium it dries down
really well and it keeps my legs really
really moisturized
um so you can find your new skincare and
body favorites at ocmalibu.com and get a
special discount just for our listeners
so that's 10 off your first order
site-wide with the promo code toast at
ocamalibu.com and osea is spelled
o-s-e-a malibu.com you'll get free
samples with every order and orders over
fifty dollars get free shipping and
You're Gonna Want It All go to osia
o-s-e-a malibu.com code toast for that
10 off thank you Claudia it's a pleasure
I feel like if I didn't live in New York
what I would be obsessed with about New
York is like oh you're coming back to
this now yeah I'm still thinking about
like what I would be into I think I
would be like trying to like LARP Gossip
Girl style so I think I would like stay
that's how I would dress to take
pictures in the park and this and that
and that's a good call that's what I
think I would think of New York and what
you know like when I think of the UK and
Downton yeah that's where my heart goes
so I got a lot of backlash yesterday for
not letting you sing
um and people said if I'm gonna be
forced to listen to your God's terrible
singing We want to hear Jackie so I'm
actually I'm gonna bow out I'll play the
music but it's on you oh sorry it's it's
all you I appreciate that but why does
it have to be one or the other why can't
we do it together like we do everything
else well maybe we can but like
yesterday you didn't join me so now I
won't join you just to like even the
score okay and then and I'm not saying
I'm gonna sing it all the time with you
I was just I guess I was feeling excited
about the final story and you just threw
me off guard like we do the same literal
thing every single day and like you
change it and it just scared me so I so
I I acted I acted out of fear like I'm
sorry I was scared and so I I would you
say you were triggered no I would say I
acted out of fear and I took it out on
you thank you and I pushed you away is
that an apology it never sounds like one
no it's an apology it's an explanation
it's a rationale it's rationalizing your
incredibly mean actions okay calm down
you hurt me to cut me to the core calm
down are you ready yes I am
It's the final story
[Music]
It's the final story I would be LARPing
as Gossip Girl
and that's a magic number
really gorgeous really well done Jackie
thank you that was painful
no not till the two for me to not sing
do you want to do one too no no no we
don't want to lose too many viewers the
final Story the Elvis director baz
Lerman explains why he didn't cast Harry
Styles as Elvis it's not every day an
actor misses out a roll misses out on a
roll because he's quote already an icon
but that's exactly what happened for
Harry Styles and that's kind of exactly
what Jackie ashtray produced it is the
as it was hitmaker was eager to slip
into Elvis's Blue Suede Shoes for the
baz Lerman biopic but unfortunately for
him the role went to Austin Butler while
it's undoubtedly heartbroken
heartbreaking for Styles as fans seeing
someone else land the lead role of the
film baz revealed it's actually because
Styles is already somewhat of an icon
himself he said Harry is a really
talented actor I would work on something
with him but the real issue with Harry
is he's Harry Styles he's already an
icon Harry and I came to a place
genuinely I mean he was just desperate
to put the suit on and explore he's such
a great spirit and I have nothing but
great things to say about Harry Style
miles but he says that Austin Butler was
born to play the king of rock right and
I also read like
Austin Butler lost his mom at like the
same age that Elvis did so I think that
boslerman thought that would be like a
great way to connect to the role and
while I do think Harry Styles was a more
obvious choice just in the sense that
like he really does like look like Elvis
and like some could say he's like the
Elvis of Our Generation
Um I agree that like he's almost too
famous yeah it's distracting yeah look
at him and you see Harry Styles and
you're trying to see Elvis so you kind
of need a blank canvas and Austin Butler
though you know you might be seeing The
Carrie Diaries when you look at him most
people are just seeing this man playing
Elvis yeah it would be like Cher playing
like a role in a movie you know
she's just share yeah it would be like
Ariana Grande playing someone and it's
like that's Ari yeah so while I did like
At first feel
not confused but just shocked at Austin
Butler this was like the job a million
girls wanted and Austin Butler was the
one who got it which I just found
interesting because he's not really
made a lot of waves in Hollywood in
terms of acting yet so I think that like
baz luhrmann wanted to be responsible
for like making a star I love a breakout
role I really do and I think we need
more stars we need more
we need more actors they're so amazing
and we need more more no but we do need
more like a-listers genuine A-list can
red carpet not on Instagram sort of
people no you're right because it's
really been like the same A-list crew
for so many years like the George
Clooney Brad Pitt Matt Damon Leo Margot
Robbie like Jennifer Lawrence it's been
like the same group for a really long
time that's a good call and we need more
and pause is rising to the occasion yeah
I feel like the new age of like A-list
serious actors is like being helmed by
like Zendaya because she is that yeah
she is that she's like can we have her
and we need more more like and I think
this might be this movie might be the
thing to put Austin Butler like on that
level yeah but I have to see it first
there are so many things that we have to
see tick tock's about Top Gun have even
made it like to me and people are
obsessed I know and I need to see it I
know
it looks really good people are like it
keeps breaking box office like weekend
after weekend it's not slowing down
which is really good because like the
movie industry needed to win like the
movie theaters needed a win yeah
I'm always happy when people are like
excited about something yeah that's like
genuine good jolly good fun jolly good
fun you know jolly good fun it's like
planes and everyone has is in a tizzy
yeah it's planes on the beach playing
volleyball like cute mustache dresses
I've never seen Top Gun and I have
literally no idea what it's about so I'm
gonna guess
I've never seen it and I have no idea so
uh planes a lot are they in the Army I
think they are
like fighter pilots I think that they
are
and are they in a war
couldn't guess couldn't tell you and
it's modern day is it 2022 or are we
remaking 1960 no I saw a guy in the
movie wearing Jorts and that could only
happen now really yeah
do you see a cell phone
what kind of planes were they I don't
know were they old I don't know
yeah I have no idea me neither like I
couldn't even tell you like what I think
the plot of the movie is is it a romance
I know it's a thriller but like I think
there's a love scene is there a girl in
the movie I think there's a love scene
that has people in a tizzy the scene
that has people in a tizzy is Miles
Teller on the beach dancing
uh and also the funnest fact about Top
Gun is that it's top gun Maverick
no top gun Maverick no I know if you
didn't hear me let me say it one more
time top gun Maverick the name of my
first love Maverick I did I did see that
and I was um I was quite taken by that
fact you know what I also realized I got
you that Maverick sweatshirt from the
Paul Brothers store t-shirt T-shirt oh I
guess it was a sweatshirt you would wear
it yeah I wore it once on the show and
like I don't I'm not like a girl who
wears t-shirts I can't explain it yeah
okay that makes sense why you didn't
wear but I only got everything was sold
out so I only got what I could that said
Maverick no I just cleaned out my closet
and I found I like saw the t-shirt and I
kept it okay good because Ben was like
what is this I'm like get away I'm like
no get it that would be so crazy if Ben
was wearing a t-shirt that said Maverick
and he didn't even know
the usurper that is literally the
blessing of Ben never watching the show
of course that we have literal fan
fiction for mavdia yeah over here
you know we we used to do this as like
we didn't but like our generation did
this yeah the kids these days do this
isn't that weird like I don't know how
to tell you yeah this this they do this
kids are not okay
they're just not doing okay how weird
they've been through so much this is
like the Bloods and the Crips you know
everyone used to do like blood yeah
blood yeah yeah no they obviously didn't
see that original Selena Gomez album
right I wouldn't want to be anybody else
[Music]
you've got every right to a beautiful
life come on who says who says we're not
perfect who says you're not worth it who
says you're the only one that's hurting
trust me that's the price of beauty who
says you're not pretty who says you're
not beautiful
who says great question Selena great way
to end the show I think it's a beautiful
way to end the show and I don't think it
gets any better than that thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millennial Morning Show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
what'd she say
subscribe how close are we where are we
at not even close and give us a thumbs
up are we also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so at
Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio
iheartradiocastbox all the places so
every listen to podcasts find out some
morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing day and we'll see you tomorrow
for hump day we're not at 90. told you
that's why I just like ignored you not
to bring shame to our family no but we
should shame you guys into subscribing
yeah we should subscribe bye bye